Joe: From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences between McDonald's in India and the US.
Joe: This is "Food Wars."
Drinks in McDonald's
India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
Drinks in the McDonald's
in the US, four sizes:
extra small, small, medium, and large.
Time to keep 'em honest.
Lost a couple drops. 26, 27 fluid ounces.
Whoo!
Hm.
Fries in India come in three sizes:
regular, medium, and large.
In America, our fries come
in four sizes, I think.
We have a small, kids,
or kids, small —
I can't tell the difference either —
medium, and large.
The medium and large
come in these really cool
new packaging where you can
just open it up like that
and it's nice and easy to share.
It's a little plate.
Good job, McDonald's. Very innovative.
But now it's time to measure
and see how much we're really getting.
Joe: First things first, the large.
175 grams.
Obviously it's different
per scoops or whatever.
Yeah, let's go here.
This one, almost exactly 100 grams.
This one,
80 grams.
Fry math, hang on.
This is, like...
yep, there you go.
That's a 20-gram difference right there.
So, you tell me, internet.
Is the kids and the small different sizes?
I don't think they are.
"Food Wars" is on it! We're on it, baby!
What about McNuggets?
Here in India, you can
order them in three sizes:
six pieces, nine pieces, and 20 pieces.
They gave it to us in
two boxes of 10 each.
Oh, is that it, India? Cute.
Our McNuggets start at four,
then you got six,
10,
20,
and not to be outdone,
booyah, 40 McNuggets.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that that is double India's
largest nugget option.
The only burger that
India shares with the US
is the McChicken,
the humble McChicken.
Not even gonna bother
with the analog scale now.
Boop!
149 grams.
Ah, just so frustrating.
Just one more gram and
it would be perfect.
With the paper? I mean, we'll do this and
shave off an eighth of an ounce.
Our McChicken weighs 140 grams.
Here is everything you'll find on the menu
at McDonald's India that you
will not find in the USA.
And here's all the McDonald's menu items
from the US you won't find in India.
Here in India, we can't really recreate
the iconic McDonald's Big Mac
because it's made from a beef patty,
and to keep to the religious sentiments
of Hindus and even Muslims,
we don't serve beef or pork
in a lot of fast-food restaurants.
We have something called
the chicken Maharaja Mac.
As you can see, it's got
three buns, two patties,
a lot of cheese and mayonnaise,
some tomatoes, onions, lettuce.
Lettuce try it now.
[ba-dum tish]
Oh, my God.
That is truly a Maharaja Mac.
If you're wondering, a raja is a king,
and a maharaja is like an emperor.
So this is clearly our
answer to the Big Mac.
Now let's taste the veg Maharaja Mac.
I think it's actually
a very cool challenge
that a lot of fast-food restaurants here
have had to adapt to the Indian palate,
as well as sensibilities of food.
We have come up with such
cool, iconic fast food
that you won't get
anywhere else in the world.
Like, look at this! This is outrageous!
There's no way to eat
this without being messy.
There's literally no way.
Mm!
Oh, my God. That's really good.
Yes to all that, looks really good.
Because of India's lack of beef,
all the American beef options
are technically exclusives.
All right.
Big Mac.
There it is, just brimming with stuff.
My go-to for, like, 20 years.
I still get it occasionally.
The classic McDonald's hamburger.
Beef patty, ketchup, and mustard.
Of course, you can get it with cheese. Hi.
You can upgrade to a double
cheeseburger or a McDouble.
What's the difference, you ask?
I'm not sure either.
So let's start with the
double cheeseburger.
Look at that. Look how yellow that is.
Beef, cheese, beef, cheese, toppos.
The McDouble is beef, cheese, beef.
So it's just one slice of cheese
in the middle, but not on top.
What's the price difference?
Can we get that on-screen?
And how much is a slice of cheese?
Joe's hack, get yourself a McDouble
and bring your own slice
of American cheese.
Booyah. Save yourself
this amount of money.
The problem with millennials today,
the reason you guys can't buy houses is
you're spending all
your money at Starbucks,
you're getting your double cheeseburgers
instead of a McDouble and
bringing your own cheese slice.
I mean, you guys are terrible with money!
You're eating, what, seven,
eight McDoubles a day like me, right?
And that adds up to, like,
at the end of the year, $18?
10,000 years later, that's
a down payment on a house.
What are you guys doing?
All right, next up is the
iconic McAloo tikki burger.
You take mashed potato, and
you fry it in breadcrumbs,
and you get this really delicious cutlet.
Here in India, they
adapted it into this burger
with a very special sauce,
some tomato, and chopped onions.
Mm. It's just so classic.
They nailed this burger.
Next up, there is a Mexican McAloo tikki,
which I assume has some
stereotypical Mexican ingredients
and flavors like jalapeño.
Yes! Jalapeño.
Mm, nice.
It's way more spicy. Good twist.
Next up, they have a McEgg burger.
McEgg. McEgg, McEgg.
I don't know why I did that.
Let's see what that looks like.
Ugh!
Sorry.
I did not expect... pesto?
Next up is a chicken kebab burger.
Every time an Indian
fast-food chain tries to adapt
an Indian special food into a burger,
I take it with a pinch of salt
because this is not what
we're used to seeing
when we think of kebabs,
but I'm going to try it,
and let's see what happens.
Mm.
It's very, very dry.
Patty has almost a
cardboard-y taste to it.
I wouldn't put those flavors together
if I was thinking kebab.
McCardboard tikki, maybe? No? OK.
That's a bit harsh. I'm sorry.
Next up is the McVeggie,
which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our McChicken.
If I had to eat this
versus the chicken one,
I would not be upset at all.
Really good.
Next up, we have two "American" burgers:
the American Cheese Supreme veg
and the American Cheese Supreme chicken.
My hunch for what makes them American
is that they will have a
nice big square of cheese
and they will not be spicy at all.
Except they have a lot
of jalapeños on them.
Joe, let me know if this
constitutes "American."
That's American cheese, my man.
That's what makes it American.
I don't know about those
other toppings, but,
yeah, it sounds about right.
All right, so this is what
the McDonald's website
says is in this burger.
"Whole-wheat buns
sourced from Maharashtra,
tangy jalapeños from Karnataka,
shredded onions grown
in local Indian farms,
and cheese from Amaravati, also in India."
Quite close to home, this burger.
Currently, this would
probably be my favorite order,
a McSpicy chicken, and
there's the vegetarian option,
which is a McSpicy paneer,
which is just leaking lettuce.
For those of you who
don't know what paneer is,
it's basically cottage cheese.
We love our paneer.
We put it in curries, we eat
it plain, we put it in kebabs.
It is so delicious. Let's try this.
Mm. It has just the right kick,
and it goes really well with the paneer.
Fair warning, while this
may have a light kick
of spice for us, it might
be a hard kick for you.
So, take everything with
a pinch of chili powder.
Gonna move up to something
called the Quarter Pounder,
and that's, like, their big burger.
So you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese.
Here it is.
I mean, it looks fake, right?
Like, "Just kidding, it's cake!"
Or the new one is, "It's
actually a candle!"
And then you can get a Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
More veggies on it, all
the junk that I brush off.
You can upgrade to a double
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
Let's take a look. Oh, man.
Look how thick this is!
And then you can get that
same double with bacon.
Yeah!
Oh, man. Skimping on the bacon. Guys!
What we lack in beef
burgers we make up for
in gourmet burgers.
That's right. Here at McDonald's India,
we have our own collection of
chef's special gourmet burgers.
Delicious.
And I think this is a rolling menu.
I think they introduce new
things from time to time.
The buns themselves
look a lot more gourmet.
You know, there's a nice
rift down the middle.
Kind of looks like a butt, but that's OK.
We're not gonna concentrate on that.
First up, we have triple
cheese American veg burger
and triple cheese American
chicken burger.
Same thing. Cheese, jalapeño,
some sauce, lettuce,
simple chicken patty, gourmet bun.
Does this scream "American" to you?
Next up, Cheese Lava American veg burger
and Cheese Lava American chicken burger,
again with American
and again with the strange relation
of food to volcanoes and lava.
OK.
This burger is very spicy.
This qualifies as a
volcano product, for sure.
Congratulations, McDonald's.
The lava in the title
of this burger works.
The McSpicy chicken premium, though,
has an egg patty inside of it.
Mm-mm.
Mm, that's pretty good.
I just feel so existential right now.
Imagine sitting here at this table
and just tasting every single
burger on a McDonald's menu.
Amazing.
But also, s---.
We also have some exclusive wrap options.
We have Big Spicy paneer
and Big Spicy chicken.
I think this is the same
McSpicy chicken patty,
and it's wrapped around a tortilla,
which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati
than most other fast-food restaurants.
It doesn't feel as synthetic.
Our McDonald's in the US
had wraps for a brief period of time.
One day they were gone. Nobody noticed.
Yeah, you guys got some chicken
stuff that we don't have,
but we got a few of our own.
More recently than you think,
they finally introduced
their chicken sandwich
to an already-crowded
chicken-sandwich market,
and that is of course their
crispy chicken sandwich,
and this thing is fantastic.
It's one of the best ones.
They were late to the game,
and they kind of took
it over, in my opinion.
And what I like about it,
it's simple. Look at this.
You just got crispy
chicken, pickles that suck.
It's baller. It tastes great.
Like it a little spicy, India?
It probably doesn't
compare to what you guys
are rocking in India but, you know,
this one has a little nice heat to it.
Pickles, sauce.
Want to take it up a notch?
Gotta go deluxe.
The cool crispness of the vegetables
just clash so well with the spicy sauce.
It's good. It's good.
Nikhil, say the word,
and I'm putting one in
the post for you tomorrow.
So when it arrives in three weeks,
you can throw it out.
Now we're getting into
exclusive side dishes.
Here in India, we have these add-ons.
No. 1, the veg pizza McPuff.
This is one of the most
delicious things we have here.
It's basically a pizza Hot Pocket.
Masala wedges. These are potato wedges
with classic Indian masala flavor to them.
Ooh, boy.
Masalas are basically what we use
to spice and flavor dishes,
and they consist primarily
of ground-up spices
like cardamom, cloves,
red chilies, Kashmiri chilies.
You go to every Indian home, the mums,
the grandmums will have
their own random, you know,
masala mix that they
use and that's guarded
and treasured in their family, forever.
Next up, we have cheesy masala wedges.
They're also serving a
classic cup of boiled corn,
which is so unique, and they
give you a side of Amul butter.
Guys, Amul butter is part of our culture.
Makhan. Makhan!
This is probably going to be
the most delicious bite of the day.
I love corn.
Next up, chicken strips.
They come in packs of two, three, or five.
Cheesy nugget veg bites.
Yeah, this is just a vegetarian version
of the chicken nuggets,
and it's got some corn, some tomato.
Mm, it's OK.
Next, we have the double cheese McMuffin.
And lastly, we have Mexican cheesy fries.
On the McDonald's India website,
one British customer said
that these Mexican cheesy
fries are "the real deal."
I have no idea how a
British person can say
that Mexican cheesy
fries are the real deal,
but anytime a British person says
that another culture's
food is "the real deal,"
it puts a little fear in
our small Indian hearts.
Yeah those fries look like ass.
And the next exclusive side
that we have is apple slices.
Cut 'em up, put 'em in a plastic bag.
'Bout to get saucy. That's
right, ladies and gentlemen.
Sauce talk.
Thank you.
Spicy Buffalo.
Not that good.
We got a tangy barbecue.
Ooh.
Much better.
Mm. Honey mustard.
Tastes like salad dressing.
Sweet and sour.
I would tie it with the tangy barbecue
because it's so different,
so we'll keep these guys
same tier.
Ranch, I don't know.
America, we love our ranch.
Ranch is just OK.
That's right, I said it. Ranch is just OK.
Oh, and all ranch tastes the same. Yeah.
And finally, honey.
How do you like that?
Honey's the best one.
And all that money, all that energy,
all that time creating all these recipes,
trying to sway the American mind,
and you got beat by a bunch of bees.
Power to the bees!
We have one exclusive spice mix
as well as one exclusive
sauce here in India.
We have chili sauce, which
is pretty straightforward.
It's chili sauce.
But let me tell you about
peri-peri spice mix.
So, McDonald's launched
this in 2013 here in India,
and it was so popular, there were riots
when they said they were
going to discontinue it.
And so now, it's a permanent
addition to the menu.
First, you get this shake bag,
then you grab your fries,
and then you just pour that in there.
Ah.
Boom! Oh, boy.
Can we cut to a before of the fries?
You saw how they were. Now look at these.
You can see the little flecks of spice
just adorning each fry.
Hello, it's Crystelle.
And I know Nikhil has
peri-peri McDonald's chips,
but in the UK, it is all about Nando's.
Cheeky Nando's.
Let's talk about peri-peri.
Peri means pepper. And
it's a blend of spices,
so it's got things like paprika,
ground bird's eye chili,
a bit of oregano, a pinch
of ginger and cardamom,
but it's a Portuguese spice blend.
It's funny because
obviously Nikhil mentioned
that the peri-peri fries
just blew off in India,
and it makes sense, because I'm from Goa,
which is in the south of India.
Goa was colonized by the Portuguese.
And so I really think that Indians
are accustomed to that
Portuguese taste palate,
which is why peri-peri fries
are doing so well in India.
But enough of the talking.
I want to dig into these
fries, because they look great.
Mm. Oh, this is so good.
Harry, get involved.
You're not eating chips
without me, are you?
Oh, sorry, I've already had a head start.
Harry: Cheers.
Crystelle: Cheers.
God damn, if that isn't like crack.
For the early risers,
there's plenty of
exclusive breakfast items
at the US McDonald's.
Sausage biscuit with egg.
Next one,
sausage biscuit.
I mean, they take the
egg out, so it's just ...
This, of course, is
bacon, egg, and cheese.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we've reached the point of the breakfast
where we get into the McGriddles.
I love McGriddles.
What's a McGriddle, you ask,
India? Fantastic question.
McDonald's had this genius idea
to replace the breakfast
sandwiches they already had
with pancakes.
And they also, like, inject
syrup into it somehow?
But it is a breakfast sandwich
with pancakes for buns,
and it's the best idea anyone's
ever had, anywhere, ever.
[Joe laughing]
Look at this! Look at this, look at this.
They've even got a little M on there.
This mini pancake.
I know I'm wearing the
gloves, but this one's mine.
Mm.
We have a veg McMuffin
and a sausage McMuffin.
Mm.
The sausage here in India
is not made out of pork,
like it is in the US.
Instead, it's made out of simple chicken.
Speaking of sausage, you
can get a breakfast burrito.
Bro, I could put five of
these away, easy. Easy.
If you're, like, a total drag
and you want oatmeal in
the morning, we have it.
It's about as inspiring
as you would think.
Hotcakes and sausage.
Of course, it comes with hot syrup.
This here,
the big breakfast with hotcakes.
And it's big.
A lot of eggs, kind of
wimpy-looking bacon,
got yourself two English muffins here.
And, of course, comes with a hash brown.
Potatoes. Who doesn't love 'em?
McDonald's hash brown, undefeated.
These things are so good.
India exclusive desserts.
We have a Black Forest McFlurry,
a vanilla chocolate muffin,
and a chocolate chip muffin.
It's kind of like a
McFlurry soup right now.
This would be really good when
it was actually a McFlurry.
Desserts! USA, we got 'em.
So, starting down here, very simple,
chocolate chip cookies.
This next thing, apple fritter, right?
Mm.
This right here is called a
glazed pull-apart doughnut.
Blueberry muffin.
If you've had one, you've had them all.
This is a what type of pie?
Anders: A guava and cream pie.
Let's see what's inside.
OK. I'm suddenly more interested. Yeah!
Guava and cream.
How about we'll call it
the cream and guava pie?
Nah, this sucks.
[Anders laughing]
I don't f--- with it.
Standard menu item, the
McDonald's apple pie.
Everyone knows about this.
I don't want a pizza version of this.
Eh! And last but not least, cinnamon roll.
Too sticky. I don't feel like eating it.
Update: It's not sticky.
It's actually [knocks on cinnamon roll].
Exclusive drinks, starting with,
we have something called
B Natural's mixed fruit juice.
Next up, we have something
that they call raw mango fruit splash.
Oh!
It's a bit too sweet.
Berry lemonade splash.
All of these come in these very unique
reusable bottles, apparently.
Next up, strawberry chiller,
green apple chiller,
and lemon chiller.
It's just flavored water.
That's exactly what it is.
It's flavored water,
and I kind of like it.
This is a mixed berry smoothie.
It's still quite sweet, but quite good.
Next up, American mud pie shake.
Mm. That's pretty yum.
Drink roulette.
Ooh, and the ice melted. Fantastic.
Dr. Pepper. Let's go!
Coke, nonexclusive. Let's go.
Sweet tea, too sweet.
Ugh, yeah. Unsweetened
tea, not sweet enough.
You guys combine.
For the kids watching,
why are you watching?
Where are your parents or supervisors?
You can get yourself apple juice, milk.
Come on, you're drinking milk?
The thought of drinking straight milk,
like, hurts my stomach.
There's also chocolate milk on the menu.
Once upon a time,
this was an iced French vanilla latte.
Now it's more of a room-temperature
French vanilla latte.
That's just OK. It's, like, really sweet.
Strawberry banana smoothie.
Yeah, I always loved getting these.
These are good.
So I'm going to assume
they're not good for me.
Exclusive hot drinks.
First off, we have strawberry green tea.
Next up, English breakfast tea
and Moroccan tea.
Next up, a flat white coffee.
India, a land where we run on chai,
and McDonald's does
not have a chai option.
Caramel macchiato,
cappuccino,
caramel latte,
a vanilla cappuccino.
The V does look like a U.
McDonald's premium roast coffee.
I'm going to hang on to this one.
In India, a chicken Maharaja
Mac will cost you 231 rupees
for just the sandwich.
That's around $3.03.
We do not have the chicken Maharaja Mac,
but we do have the Big Mac,
and a Big Mac in the US costs $4.89.
That is a 61% price increase.
Now, what if you turn this into a meal?
A McSaver Maharaja Mac combo
comes with regular fries
and a regular drink and
will cost you 356 rupees.
That is $4.67, still less than the price
of the American sandwich on its own.
But does the combo meal
make a difference in the US?
A medium Big Mac combo,
so Big Mac, medium fries, medium drink,
is $8.99.
That's a 92% cost increase,
even worse than if you just
bought the sandwich on its own.
On the Indian McDonald's menu,
you'll find a two-person meal,
which contains a chicken
Maharaja Mac, a veg Maharaja Mac,
large fries, two pizza
McPuffs, and a drink.
All of this will cost
you 681 rupees, or $8.93.
So, basically, you're
getting food for two people
for the price of one
person's meal in the US.
However, while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the US,
it's still very expensive
and aspirational to people over here.
Your minimum wage per hour
is equal to our daily minimum wage.
And so, yeah,
a lot of people can't really
afford this kind of food.
The English-speaking Indians that you see
in a lot of YouTube videos on the internet
aren't really a proper reflection
of the majority of people
that live in this country,
who still can't afford food like this.
So, I'm checking my privilege,
and we should all make sure we check ours.
But let's play devil's advocate.
McDonald's India has definitely included
a lot more affordable
options on their menu.
And so they are more approachable
to the average urban Indian
than other fast-food chains.
Let's compare some items
to see who has the least
healthy McDonald's food.
In the US, a McChicken
contains 400 calories,
21 grams of fat, 39 grams of carbs.
5 of those are sugar,
and 560 milligrams of sodium.
How about the Indian McChicken?
One of these contains 398 calories,
15 grams of total fat, 48 grams of carbs,
5 grams of which are sugars,
787 milligrams of sodium.
So the Indian version has
slightly fewer calories,
way lesser fats, but much
more carbs and sodium.
What if we made that a combo meal?
Well, a medium fry in the
US contains the following:
320 calories, 15 grams of total fat,
43 grams of carbs, no sugar,
and 260 milligrams of sodium.
While a medium fries in
India contains 340 calories,
17 grams of total fat, 41 grams of carbs,
0 grams of sugars,
and 256 milligrams of sodium.
And if we add the medium Coke,
that is adding 210 calories, no fat,
56 grams of carbs, 56 of those are sugar,
and 55 milligrams of sodium.
Ooh, a nice salty Coke.
We'll do the same. Here in India,
one medium Coke will
cost you 151 calories,
0 grams of fat, 38 grams of carbs,
38 grams of which are sugars,
and there are 0 grams
of sodium, but my God,
that is a lot of sugar packed in this cup.
That leaves the Indian
meal at a grand total
of 889 calories, 32 grams of fat,
127 grams of carbs,
out of which 43 grams are sugars,
and 1,043 milligrams of sodium.
Sheesh.
Which means this whole bad boy altogether
is 930 calories,
36 grams of total fat,
138 grams of carbs,
61 of those grams are sugar,
875 milligrams of sodium.
Little bit lower sodium than India,
but we got you guys beat in
calorie, fats, carbs, and sugar.
Mm, mm, mm, mm! We win. We win.
Ah!
Unfortunately for India,
the combo stats are a little misleading,
and the difference maker is the Coke,
because the American meal
has a larger portion.
If you order the Coke
Zero in both countries,
the Indian meal will actually
have a higher calorie count.
McDonald's India does
not share a full list
of their ingredients,
but there are some things
we do know about their food.
Like, did you know that McDonald's India
actually changed Indian farming practices
just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted?
When they first launched in India in 1996,
McDonald's promised the government
that they would use products grown
and sourced right here in India.
But people who had eaten McDonald's abroad
realized that the fries
didn't taste quite the same.
The reason for this is
that Indian potatoes
were too small, round,
had way too much moisture
and sugar content.
And so the fries made out of
them were not long enough,
they didn't get crispy
enough, and they didn't have
that distinctive McDonald's oomph to them.
So, McDonald's partnered
with McCain Foods,
and they spent nine years
trying to perfect their potato.
They imported saplings
which had the perfect shape
and starch content that they needed.
They also chose Gujarat
as their farming location
for its climate, and they switched
from a flood irrigation
to a sprinkler system
to reduce moisture content and save water.
The result: bigger and
more starchy potatoes
that can be used to make
the McDonald's fries
that you know and love.
McDonald's in the US
mostly uses russet Burbank
or Shepody, "shep-a-tee," potatoes.
Potato me.
So, these are big enough that
the distinctive long fry,
yeah, look how long this is. Wow!
Known to be low moisture
and low sugar content.
This means they can
remain crispy when fried
and don't caramelize too fast,
so you can get a nice, even browning.
McDonald's in the US actually discloses
all of its ingredients,
so we can figure out a
few other differences.
In the US, for instance,
our mayonnaise contains egg yolk,
as does most American mayo.
Thanks to the FAQ page on
the McDonald's India website,
we found out that the
mayonnaise is eggless,
along with all of the other sauces
except for the tartar sauce.
When people describe things
as vegetarian here in India,
they typically mean it
doesn't contain egg.
Did we quietly retire
Ronald and the crew?
If we did, thank God.
It was very bizarre, the
whole Ronald McDonald thing.
It's kind of nightmarish.
So, away he goes.